mary kay cabot the Browns beat writer
for the Cleveland Plain Dealer Mary take
me to Saturday when you got the word
that Josh Gordon had or was going to be
released what were you told what was
your reaction well I was pretty shocked
that he was released because we knew
something was going wrong we do things
were not right based on things I had
seen Friday and practice and things I
had been hearing about what happened on
Saturday morning but I was actually
quite shocked that they took the measure
to go ahead and release him actually now
I think it will be a trade at some point
very soon they will explore all these
possibilities and see what they can get
for him but I have to admit I was quite
shocked it got to this point okay why
was he released well they're saying that
they were going to release him and you
know because of apparently it had gotten
to the point where they were just done
but when I did a bunch of reporting I
made a bunch of phone calls I came
across the fact that he showed up not
only late I'm sorry but that he was not
himself there was a feeling in the
organization that he was still
struggling with his sobriety and that
they had done all that they could to
help him the hamstring promotion you
know pull at the promotional video shoot
was really not the reason why they
decided to part ways with him that was
just one more red flag or sort of
bizarre circumstance in this whole saga
explain this promotional shoot that he
was on where he got injured was this a
team sanctioned promotional shoot no and
it's kind of weird that he was actually
at the team facility during a
promotional shoot around 11 o'clock at
night it is bizarre it's weird no one
really knows exactly why he was doing
that but you know I think if he had to
get up early and be at work the next
morning
you know Josh is at a point in his life
where he needs to be either in his
playbook or sleeping or doing something
else to be the best version of himself
in the game on Sunday not risking being
late the next morning which she was so
it was just a poor decision on his part
to be worrying about something like that
the night before they were about to
leave for New Orleans what I keep
hearing about Josh
or news he doesn't love football Mary
Kay is that can can you acknowledge that
or is that a fair assessment here you
know I don't really know if it's the
case or not I can't get insight you know
Josh's head he claims to love football
he claimed to love the Cleveland Browns
I'm not so sure about that
but it's hard to say whether or not he
loves football and it's hard to know
what to believe with him you know if
he's in his active addiction at times
you know I I do find it difficult to
believe some of the things that he says
I quite often am skeptical when I stand
in front of him and he talks about you
know being committed and changed and all
those sorts of things I hope that's the
case I hope he can get it together but I
think it's very unfortunate that if and
when he really does that the Browns who
have stuck by him through thick and thin
will not get to reap the benefits of a
healthy and good Josh Gordon as far as
his trade value how much value does he
have we know talent wise but what can
Cleveland expect to restore hope to
receive in return well that's going to
get interesting I wouldn't do it unless
somebody knocked my socks off with an
offer I would not let him go and I
wouldn't be in a rush to do it the trade
deadline isn't until next month I don't
know why you know you would feel
compelled to do this I would hold out
and get the most and the best that you
could get for him I don't know what the
market is right now I know there are
about 8 to 10 teams calling so let these
guys get into a bidding war and see what
they see what they can get out of that
maybe they could get a kicker in return
Mary Kay well they certainly meet one
and they are trying some out today and I
don't think that same result will be
long for this team I don't know if they
have enough time to get this done in
time for their Thursday night game
against the Jets but he will not be
around much longer did you talk to him
did he talk to the media after their
performance yes he was very very
remorseful it was you know difficult to
even stand there and talk to him because
he was very very upset about this whole
thing he said he's let down the team he
took full responsibility and blame he's
always been a and
standing guy he's a young occur only in
his second year but he just it's snow
balled on him and it just got away from
him and when he got to that final
52-yard attempt instead of the wide left
that he had done in the previous three
kicks he over compensated and went wide
right so just a horrible nightmare of a
day that could be two and oh right now
instead of old one and one who do you
think they're going to bring in they've
got a couple of guys in today that not
real big-name guys but apparently Dan
Bailey has said that he's not interested
in trying out for them and he's going to
have a lot of opportunities for himself
and he's saying that he wants to go to
the right team and apparently that's not
the crowd so they've got some younger
guys in and I've been flying all morning
so I'm just landing now here in Dulles
on my way back to Cleveland and I
haven't been able to really pin down
exactly who they have in but they have
at least two guys in today it's always
interesting Mary Kay we appreciate your
time as always thank you thank you
that's Mary Kay comet Cleveland Plain
Dealer for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]